The general experience,
Michael Jackson was not an ecstatic
onstage.
Michael Jackson wasn't incredible,
astonishing performer who had studied
his craft from the age of nine,
and so he worked out every single move
and advance John,
you never knew from one night to the
next what prince or John Mellencamp
we're going to do in performance.
They didn't know how well did you know
Michael Jackson?
I thought very,
very well and he was the most remarkable
person I've ever met in my life.
And when I tell people how remarkable
they don't believe me,
he was,
you know,
and I and Jamie are on a certain level
and we don't know.
We're on a certain level because we
figured these are the range.
This is the range of humanity.
If we go out and meet anybody on the
street or even anybody famous,
I work with Buzz Aldrin these days.
What we're gonna encounter is another
person pretty much like costs.
Sorry.
In Michael Jackson's case,
he did not fit on this normal plain at
all.
He was on a plane somewhere where you've
never seen a human being before.
So the first time I met him,
we were at his brother Marlin's,
have pool house.
It's a little house with just enough
room for one big room on the first floor
and another big room on the second floor
with a little tiny staircase between
them and there's a billiard table in the
middle of the room and their arcade
games,
which at that point in particular in
1983,
um,
were unattainable.
No human could afford arcade games,
um,
unless you were Steve Wynn and you were
actually equipping and arcade.
So we're in the middle of.
We're in this room and Michael and I are
standing next to each other,
so his elbow is that his left elbow is
at my right elbow.
His left knee is at my right knee and we
have a meeting with the art director
from CBS.
I'm condensing the story,
there's lots more,
but we're having a meeting with the art
director and she walks in with five of
the most gorgeous portfolios you've ever
seen in your life.
Hand carved Cherrywood,
hand carved leather.
And these are from guys I know because I
was,
I started in pop culture in the art
business and these were my legendary
competitors and um,
and Michael opens the first page of the
first portfolio and he gets a square
inch into it,
a postage stamp sized piece into it.
And he goes,
oh.
And his knees began to buckle and he
gets another two square inches into.
It just lifts the page a little bit
further.
Oh,
he lifts it up even further.
Michael was seeing the infinite in the
things that even the artist didn't see
it with such infinity.
As Michael is singing.
And by this time he gets to the full
page,
he's having a full scale aesthetic
orgasm.
I have never seen anything like this in
my life.
And I remember the first two rows of
science are the truth at any price,
including the price of your life.
And look at things run under right under
your nose as if you've never seen them
before.
And then proceed from there.
Michael is seeing the infinite in the
tiniest of things.
And you never seen a human with this
degree of awe,
wonder and surprise anywhere in your
life.
And I will never see another human like
that again in my lifetime.
Michael was beyond belief,
utterly beyond belief and his commitment
to his audience,
to his,
the people he called his kids.
Oh God,
I forgot to turn this off.
A very different perspectives.
And I said,
I booked this show.
It's in six months.
I need 40 minutes.
It's got to be.
And he's,
he has told some of my stories and vice
before getting drunk with sumo wrestlers
and different,
different stories.
And how much do you weigh?
A One?
50 six.
And you got drunk with sumo wrestlers?
Scary.
Oh no,
it was really like,
it was joyous.
It was.
You've never seen anything like this
became big though.
Yeah.
Oh,
you should see it.
So Byamba,
do you know who Byamba is?
He's like,
okay.
So if you ever see us Sumal on TV that's
beyond.
So he's the guy like the GEICO
commercial skating dot being a figure
skater,
tiger woods of sumo wrestling.
And he is a genius.
He's a world champion,
but he's also an entertainer,
so he lives in Hollywood and he's very,
very loose here.
Yeah,
yeah.
He is a sumo wrestler.
Yeah.
There he is.
Yeah,
he is from Mongolia.
But he spends a great deal of time here
working as a television personality and
an actor and whatever,
but he just looked fat.
Oh,
he's got it looks jacked.
Like go to that one where he's doing the
muscle.
Po's that are there.
Yeah.
So that's like those shoulder muscles
through all that fat.
That guy looks like a tank.
Well,
people don't realize,
but underneath there is like you or
underneath Eris like Tj dillashaw.
You know what I mean?
There is a muscular person underneath
all those additional layers of fat and
flush and skin.
There was,
there was a powerful athlete and that's
a real benefit and being that fat.
Yeah.
Force power generation like momentum.
The ability.
I mean if the other guy is that big and
our goal is just to smash into each
other until one of us has taken from the
platform,
you're not that big.
It's going to be very difficult.
Right.
So it's like an arms race of size over
generations where they just got bigger
and bigger out of necessity because if
you're bigger,
I mean,
what am I going to do?
Go back to this thing and,
and tell me what has been the reaction,
like when you take it,
how you feed your scoring and just like
a cup of coffee,
you really do feel like you do you do
feel more energy.
Do you think it's because of the fencing
or is it possible that they just live
within the gen sing and that makes the
story sexier for the website that sells?
So you think just eating the ants
themselves give you haven't injury.
I would imagine that you'd have to catch
a lot of ants to get what you get out of
like all the powdered extract that they,
what they sell you.
Right?
But I mean eating the powdered extract.
Then just that somehow or another.
What's the mechanism for giving you
energy?
Uh,
there's some chemical that's in the
ants.
Hud,
I don't know the mechanism of action.
Again,
I like,
hi.
I really don't claim to be an expert in
index extract,
but yet you've got a bottle and I'm sure
I have,
I have a bottle of it was,
it was in with all my other supplements
in it and uh,
I was packing up this morning and
thought it would be an interesting one.
It is interesting to show it to you.
Just a giant bottle of that says aunt on
it.
What is the,
what's the standard way that people take
it to the daughter or as a tincture?
Yeah,
I would imagine you could probably put
it in a smoothie,
you know,
with your,
with your bee pollen,
other insect derivatives.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But yeah,
what a weird one.
Huh?
And this guy,
when I was young,
it was beating me up and the bus all the
time.
It was ridiculous.
Really Collides me.
I'd like,
I did that spence that you can tight
like this.
It was,
I take enough.
And so I was that gun on dowhere and
find everybody in front of a girl.
He was beating me up all the time and it
was stronger than me.
Was like treat four years older than me
and it was tall and strong.
Guys,
I'll keep layer back in the day and now
I couldn't beat him.
It given him with Marshall,
it was always stronger than me.
He hurt me a lot,
like back in the day and so my dad,
one time I was got beat up in the bus.
I told him because I came back with a
black guy one time in my life.
I told my dad what happened.
I never said anything,
but I sent my dad to say,
yeah.
He's like,
I ended up bus.
He beat me up and said,
tell him the name of the guy.
So my dad was.
He did
you found out where?
I'm from countryside so everybody knows
who everybody lives.
It goes to Dallas.
Know I can tell the dog to the Daddy,
say,
listen and stuff.
Can you tell your son to stop hitting my
son in the bus because he need to be
focused on this school and that Dad,
when my dad came back he said,
hey,
I went to talk to his dad is going to
stop.
So he said that is that it was like
drinking and stuff and it was beating
the shit out of his son.
So the way this guy learn to communicate
to his dad was beating up.
He was drunk and beating him up.
That's the way it was communicate,
communicating with me.
It was beating me up because he learned
that the same way from is that to
communicate.
So I was just happened to be at the
right,
right the wrong time at the right time
in his life at the perfect,
you know,
I was the guy that was getting beat.
So when I say good and bad,
he was not a bad person to my version of
life too,
for my perspective.
It was a terrible person back them.
It was terrible.
I wanted to kill him.
You and like many making my and my
school time miserable man.
I wasn't affiliated all the time.
It was getting beat up and I had,
I was very proud person.
So I used to go fight him all the time
because I was proud and at one point I
fought him.
So many times you say,
I like this guy,
he's completely insane.
I stop buttering him because I was never
good at giving up even though it was
beating,
getting beat up all the time,
but to my arm eyes he was a bad person,
but true.
His eyes,
it was a different star.
We enjoy.
His spotter was a different story today.
Everybody.
It was a different story just to say
that when I met him that way we talk
about like,
it feels so good just to meet him in the
street and make kind of a piece and give
him money.
Like,
yeah,
you beat me up.
You didn't.
But you know what?
Even though you did that,
I give you the money and I made me feel
like I'm kind of a revenge.
Better than a revenge.
You make me feel like,
yeah man,
you see without me,
you wouldn't have nothing maybe to sleep
or eat tonight,
so I give it to you.
I still give it to you if you do that to
me,
that make me feel much better than if I
would like beat him up.
Yeah.
So you,
you ended up revaluing those kinds of
things and that the,
so that was a really important takeaway
for me.
The other was having an experience of
ego dissolution that which can be scary,
can also be very blissful if it's then
followed by a merging with nature or
other people.
And I do think that is the therapeutic
agent in these people who are healed,
that our ego does keep us from
perceiving certain things and it
enforces really destructive stories.
We tell ourselves like I can't get
through this day without a drink.
I'm unworthy of love.
Uh,
you know,
the voice of self criticism all and we
get trapped in these loops.
And especially as we get older.
And that's one of the reasons I think
psychedelics are actually more valuable
the older you get because we are
creatures of habit.
And by now we have these mental
algorithms that organize our,
our,
our response to everything.
And sure,
that's very efficient,
but it blinds you to experience.
It blinds you to the every day,
wonders and secondary,
you know,
softens those habits and,
and,
and helps you get out of those grooves.
And for me that was really useful and
it's only,
I think it's the experience of ego
dissolution that allows you to.
Because your ego enforces those habits
and you get a little break.
There's a beautiful metaphor.
One of the scientists I interviewed in
the book,
a Dutchman working in imperial college
in London,
he said,
think of your mind is a hill covered in
snow and your thoughts are sleds going
down that hill and after awhile after a
lot of thoughts have gotten that hill,
there'll be these grooves.
And then getting to get deeper and
deeper and a certain point,
you can't go down the hill without
slipping into those groups.
That's who we are is we're like,
you know,
at this age.
And um,
what psychedelics do,
he said his is flattened,
the snow,
lots of fresh powder and you can then
take the slit anyway you want to go.
That is a great way of describing it.